nous en arrivons donc à la discussion de
la motion tendant au renvoi en
commission
déposée par le président jean claude
gaudin et les membres de l'union pour un
mouvement populaire et la parole et à
monsieur philippe bas pour la motion
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
monsieur présidente de la commission
madame et monsieur les rapporteurs on
aimerait pouvoir donner acte aux
gouvernements de ces bonnes intentions
davantage de sénatrice des villes mieux
représenter une plus grande diversité
politique tels sont les objectifs
affichés de ce texte hélas
vous n'avait manifestement pas oublier
que charité bien ordonnée commence par
soi même car au delà des apparences il y
a les réalités politiques
elles sont d'ailleurs tellement limpide
que l'on note que l'on aurait aimé voir
le gouvernement les assumer sans détour
la féminisation la représentation des
villes le pluralisme sont des prétextes
l'essentiel est ailleurs vous voulez
fortifier la gauche lors des prochains
renouvellements du sénat et vous
réclamez à la loi électorale une
garantie de résultat
jamais on aura en si peu de temps
tenté de modifier autant de règles du
jeu électoral et comme par hasard
alors que dans les départements
le parti socialiste court circuite les
préfets en élaborant lui même la carte
des nouveaux cantons pour le compte du
ministère de l'intérieur
voici que nous sommes invités à
délibérer toutes affaires cessantes du
mode de scrutin sénatorial
cartels sont bien aujourd'hui les
urgences du gouvernement alors que la
france est entrée en récession que le
chômage explose et que les chiffres de
la délinquance ne s'est hélas de
progresser dans les circonstances
nationales et internationales que nous
traversons l'agenda gouvernemental
n'est pas seulement déroutant voire
surréaliste il est un con
il serait tout à fait vain de vouloir
vous approprier la rénovation et la
déontologie de la vie publique pour
reprendre la formulation de la mission
confiée à monsieur jospin par le chef de
l'état aucun d'entre nous n'est obligé
d'invoquer la morale à l'appui de chacun
de ses actes mais qui croit pouvoir le
faire
s'expose plus que d'autres à être jugé à
se tourner
or de morale je n'en vois guère dans ce
texte rien ne vous arrête dans votre
travail méthodique de déconstruction de
ce qui fait l'originalité de
l'institution sénatoriales
est votre projet sur les
incompatibilités
demanda amplifierait encore ce travail
de déconstruction en empêchant les
sénateurs de demeurer mer
parmi les maires élus locaux parmi les
élus locaux
la seule chose qui vous retiennent
encore heureusement c'est la
constitution que vous n'avez pas le
droit de modifier sans notre accord et
c'est le conseil constitutionnel qui a
interdit en 2000 que le collège
sénatoriales soit déséquilibré et
dénaturée par la désignation massive de
délégués non élus
cela n'a pourtant pas empêché lionel
jospin de proposer de nouveau à la fin
de l'année dernière un système par up
d'effet équivalent où l'on aurait vu
partout pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de la république
des délégués sénatoriaux disposer chacun
de plusieurs voies jusqu'à 15 cette
astuce n'aurait certainement pas trompé
le conseil constitutionnel mais il faut
donner acte aux gouvernements monsieur
le ministre de sa sagesse puisqu'il y a
finalement renoncé
la crainte du juge constitutionnel est
pour vous le commencement de la raison
politique
je tiens à rappeler ce que dit l'article
24 de notre constitution
je le cite le sénat est élu au suffrage
universel indirect il assure
la représentation des collectivités
territoriales de la république les
français établis hors de france sont
représentées au sénat
dans la mesure où il assure la
représentation des collectivités
territoriales de la république le sénat
doit être élu par un corps électoral lui
même composé principalement d'élus de
ces collectivités c'est le conseil
constitutionnel qui le dit et c'est le
critère principal
de la composition du sénat
vous auriez le droit de remettre en
cause les fondements historiques de
notre institution ils n'ont pas changé
depuis la 3ème république gambetta déjà
critique qualifier notre assemblée de
grands conseils des communes de france
mais vous ne pouvez pas feindre de vous
étonner que les délégués des communes
domine le collège sénatoriales et que ce
faisant les communes rurales ils soient
représentés en fonction de leur nombre
et de leur population d'ailleurs c'est à
dire d'une manière qui ne laisse qu'une
moindre place aux communes urbaines car
c'est une donnée de départ de
l'institution sénatoriales dans notre
république si l'on veut parvenir à une
égale représentativité démographique
ce n'est pas la loi électorale qu'il
faut changer il faut changer le sénat
lui même
il n'est d'ailleurs pas interdit d'en
discuter
les constituants aurait pu concevoir un
autre sénat ou pas de senna du tout nous
ne sommes pas là pour assurer une
défense corporatives de notre
institution celle-ci ne vaut que par son
apport au bon fonctionnement
de notre régime parlementaire
pour le service de la france et le
service des français mais se trouve que
la république depuis longtemps voulu
qu'à côté de l'assemblée du peuple
sierre dans notre parlement une
assemblée des territoires dans notre
nation une et indivisible
marquée par plusieurs siècles
d'absolutisme royal puis de centralisme
républicain la république a ainsi veillé
à placer au coeur du parlement un
puissant défenseur des libertés locales
c'est un contrepoids
indispensable à notre tradition jacobine
avec les inévitables excès de pouvoir
qu'amplifie encore aujourd'hui le fait
majoritaire le sénat reste aujourd'hui
le meilleur antidote que nous ayons
trouvé pour combattre les volontés
uniformisatrice par essence négatrice
des libertés locales et qui ne cesse
d'être à l'oeuvre dans notre système
politique exagérément étatisée alors si
l'on admet l'utilité et même la
nécessité du sénat il faut admettre
aussi une composition qui tout en
respectant autant que possible l'égalité
de suffrages assume non pas comme une
anomalie mais comme un bienfait une
représentation de nos territoires pour
eux-mêmes les collectivités
territoriales de la république ne
peuvent être taillée comme de simples
circonscription qui serait destiné à
l'expression du suffrage universel
indirect
ce sont des communautés humaines bien
vivante et qui font vivre la citoyenneté
la france n'accepte pas voulu d'un
régime fédéral qui n'auraient
correspondu en rien à son histoire mais
depuis la révision constitutionnelle de
2003 proposée par jacques chirac et par
jean pierre raffarin la constitution
proclame que la république est
décentralisée
le moment serait historiquement bien mal
choisi pour affaiblir la représentation
des territoires par le sénat en partant
du principe qu elle est suspecte
votre réforme même modeste porte en
germe la négation de l'identité de notre
assemblée
vous avez le droit de dire que le sénat
vous gêne un débat sur cette question ne
serait pas sans intérêt ce serait un
débat constitutionnel tout à fait digne
de notre démocratie le sénat n'aurait
d'ailleurs rien à redouter
il n'est pas inféodé
au pouvoir en place pas plus hier
qu'aujourd'hui
il sait dire non et quand il dit oui il
sait le faire autour de majorités
d'idées il est libre il sait prendre ses
distances avec le système bi partisan
qui irradie aujourd'hui la plupart de
nos institutions et c'est peut-être la
raison pour laquelle les français ont de
l'estimé pour lui plusieurs fois dans
son histoire le peuple français a eu
l'occasion de trancher la question du
bicamérisme ce fut le cas en 46 comme en
69 mais si comme votre ancien premier
ministre lionel jospin vous estimez
toujours que le sénat est une anomalie
démocratique assumer le dit le diraison
les conséquences et si au contraire
depuis que vous y êtes majoritaires
notre institution trouve enfin grâce à
vos yeux ne cherchez plus à la dénaturer
et cesser de saper ses fondements
constitutionnels par des critiques
incessantes sur sa composition un règles
constitutionnelles inchangé jamais en
effet vous ne parviendrez à atteindre
l'objectif d' équilibre démographique
que vous ne cessez de poursuivre car il
est antinomique avec la représentation
des collectivités
territoriales par des élus de celle-ci
qu'impose l'article 24 de la
constitution
prenez 2 à 2 des départements français
ego en population
vous verrez à quel point le nombre de
communes y est différent pas de calais
895 yvelines 262
alpes-maritimes 163 moselle 730 manche
601 drôme
369 on pourrait ainsi poursuivre
indéfiniment la conséquence logique de
ce constat c'est que la composition du
collège sénatoriales ne peut que
refléter d'importants écarts d'un
département à l'autre si comme
l'imposent notre loi fondamentale l'on
veut représenter toutes les communes
il n'y a pas lieu de s'en scandaliser
puisqu'il s'agit de représenter
démocratique les territoires et non la
population elle-même comme à l'assemblée
nationale
tant que nous vivrons sous le régime de
la constitution de la vème république
le critère dominant de la composition du
sénat restera en effet la représentation
démocratique des collectivités
territoriales est donc celle des
communes dans leurs derniers diversité
par le suffrage indirect
ce n'est ni anodin ni secondaire
puisqu'il s'agit de la légitimité propre
de notre assemblée le fil qui relie le
sénat aux élus des communes ne doit pas
être rompu ni même distendus par votre
réforme
vous allez effrité cette légitimité les
roder la fragiliser en ajoutant au
collège sénatoriales une fournée de
grands électeurs non élu par le peuple
transposant habilement les méthodes en
usage sous la restauration
ce faisant vous faites le choix de la
politisation en insufflant davantage
d'esprit partisan là où le pouvoir
constituant avait surtout voulu assurer
l'ancrage du sénat dans l'expérience des
responsabilités locales
ce n'est décidément pas la bonne voie
même si au type de la correction
démographique le conseil constitutionnel
a admis des tempéraments à l'exigence de
désignation des représentants des
communes parmi les seuls élus municipaux
à condition toutefois de ne pas aller
trop loin dans cette direction
hasardeuse je vais tout de même rappeler
que
réserve faite de l'italie partout où
existe un sénat c'est-à-dire
principalement dans les pays fédéraux ce
n'est pas la recherche des équilibres
démographiques qui l'emportent dans la
composition de la deuxième chambre mais
la représentation des territoires
clairement identifiés pour notre part
nous tenons d'ailleurs déjà beaucoup
mieux compte de la démographie que les
autres pays c'est en quoi notre système
est tout de même démocratiquement
supérieur au leur même s'il est plus
difficile à caractériser par ce qu'il
est en réalité hybride
ainsi aux états unis et je viendrai
ensuite à l'allemagne justement le
wyoming le vermont et le dakota du nord
où chacun deux sénateurs pour moi de
sept cent mille habitants
autant que la californie le texas où
l'état de new york avec plus de 19
millions d'habitants pauvres américains
en allemagne monsieur le président en
réponse au maine la rhénanie du nord
westphalie dispose de six sièges au
bundesrat pour 18 millions d'habitants
autant que la bavière avec 12 millions
et demi d'habitants et seulement 1 de
plus que la s qui n'a que six millions
d'habitants et que va-t-on faire en
france on va essayer de grignoter ici ou
là quelques voix supplémentaires en
ajoutant aux élus municipaux une poignée
de militants bien choisies au nom d'un
prétendu principe d'égal
représentativité des délégués
sénatoriaux pourtant refusé par la
constitution récusé par le conseil
constitutionnel
et de toute façon hors d'atteinte sans
une réforme constitutionnelle radical
que vous ne proposez pas
cette approche
n'est pas à la hauteur de notre
institution et ne saurait se parer des
vertus de l'ambition démocratique
l'application de la représentation
proportionnelle dans les départements
comptant trois sénateurs constitue elle
aussi un recul
trois élus ce n'est pas assez pour
appliquer correctement la représentation
proportionnelle sans prendre le risque
de la confusion
loin d'être un facteur de pluralisme
dans ces départements elle favorisera
les deux principaux partis et
l'attribution du troisième siège il
ressemblera malheureusement à une sorte
de loterie ce ne seront plus les
résultats électoraux qui font qu'ils
feront directement de manière lisible
l'élection mais de savants calculs
mathématiques
vous y voyez peut-être un avantage de
favoriser l'élection des sénatrices
c'est très discutable car lorsque ce
système a été appliqué une première fois
on a vu fleurir les 10 permettant à des
sénateurs sortants qui avait sans doute
de bonnes raisons de penser qu'ils
n'avaient pas démérité et qu'il serait
injuste de les remplacer de tenter leur
chance souvent d'ailleurs avec succès au
demeurant au demeurant que ceux qui
n'ont de cesse de rappeler hors de
propos l'exigence d'égalité devant le
suffrage universel
quand il s'agit d' altérer la
composition du collège des grands
électeurs se souviennent que la
disqualification de candidats du seul
fait qu'ils sont de sexe masculin est
une telle dérogation aux principes
constitutionnels les plus solidement
établi qu'il a fallu une révision de la
constitution à 99 pour l'autoriser le
recul manque encore pour apprécier les
conséquences de cette exception à nos
règles démocratiques
on me permettra de continuer à penser
qu'en matière de discrimination positive
la plus grande prudence reste justifiée
les restrictions de fait la liberté
candidature peuvent faire progresser
l'accès des femmes à la vie publique
certainement mais elles ne font
aucunement progresser la démocratie et
ce n'est d'ailleurs ni leurs fonctions
ni leur but alors chers collègues
monsieur de ministre le sénat devrait
être sensible à la sollicitude du
gouvernement qui veut bien s'intéresser
à lui en proposant de modifier sa
constance à composition toutefois il n'a
nul besoin d'une telle attention si vous
voulez radicalement changé l'esprit et
la légitimité du sénat vous avez à votre
disposition une procédure de révision de
la constitution qui est engagée libre à
vous d'y ajouter des éléments sur la
composition du sénat pour assurer l'égal
représentativité des sénateurs ce n'est
pas ce que vous avez décidé de faire
mais quant à nous nous souhaitons que la
commission puisse se pencher de manière
élargie sur la question du bicamérisme à
partir de votre proposition tel est le
sens de la motion de renvoi en
commission que j'ai eu l'honneur de
défendre à cette tribune